Wesley, as challenging as some
of our days might be with him,
I wouldn't want to change
him for the world
because he is just the
happiest little thing.
My name is Jim Baird
and I am Tori Baird.
We have two boys, Wesley and Hudson.
Wesley is just a little light for us.
Wesley's non-verbal, but yet he
finds a way to say so much,
just with his expressions
and his million-dollar smile.
We noticed around four months,
Wesley wasn't tracking with his eyes.
He's not reaching for toys
the way he typically should be.
He's still not walking or crawling
or making really good eye contact.
So we're kind of coming
to our own conclusion
that obviously something's going on here.
We just felt like all this kind of joy
and the idea of how things
were gonna be as new parents and
all the hopes and dreams we saw for
our kid were replaced with
concern and worry and fear.
Our genetics counselor, I remember
her saying, the bloodwork came back
and Wesley has a syndrome called FoxG1,
and she's like, “How do you feel?”
And I remember thinking,
I don't know what FoxG1 is.
I have no idea what you're saying to me.
And she kind of went through her
paperwork and explained it to us.
FoxG1 Syndrome is a monogenic
neurodevelopmental disorder.
It is caused by the mutation
of the FoxG1 gene.
FoxG1 gene is actually one of
the first and most
critical genes in early brain development.
I could feel my heart being ripped
out of my chest at this point,
and I just remember sitting there
with Wesley on my lap and holding him
tighter and tighter.
They give you this
life-changing news that they don't
have very much information about.
They don't know what it could mean
long-term for Wesley,
what his life is gonna look like.
Jim was driving and we had to
pull over at one point and
just, like, cry and we're googling FoxG1.
And I remember
reading what the symptoms are.
One of them was uncontrollable laughter.
Wesley started laughing in the back seat,
while Jim and I are, like,
horribly devastated.
And I remember thinking,
maybe it's gonna be okay.
Maybe this isn't so bad if one of
his symptoms is laughing, you know?
Me and Tori just stood up
straight and looked at each other
and just basically said that it was
gonna be business as usual.
I just looked at him
and I told him that he was going to be
my best bud no matter what.
It's not a super huge community of people
that have been diagnosed with FoxG1
because it is still fairly
new as far as syndromes go,
but there's likely more people out there
who have not been diagnosed.
We have a little Facebook group
of caregivers of those
with FoxG1, so we reach out to each other
and ask, “Do you deal with this?
How do you deal with that?”
And it's also just nice to know
that there are other people out there
who know what we're going through,
and it gives us hope.
One of the things that makes Wesley
the happiest is when he hears
all the birds chirping,
and he just has a big smile on his face.
We're lucky enough to have those outdoor
skills and knowledge.
Being in nature is good for anyone,
but it's especially good for Wesley.
Wesley became more aware
of his surroundings,
and that came with being outdoors.
There's no cure for FoxG1 Syndrome.
You could sink into a really sad state.
When you get into that state,
you're unable to find the energy to care
for your child who has disabilities.
You're unable to take care of yourself.
It's gonna have its challenges,
but at the end of the day,
you're gonna love them anyways,
and they're gonna teach you so much.
Every time you fall down into
these negative thoughts,
you have to replace them
with positive thoughts.
I have confidence that
Wesley is gonna progress
and there might be more treatments
that could help Wesley, that his brother’s
gonna be there to help him,
and essentially they're gonna lead
fulfilled lives and do good for the world.